[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka homie lander
and though i've talked about black noir
in the tv show a hell of a
hell of a lot i've not really touched
down on how he's portrayed in the comic
books
i've just finished another read-through
of the boys and i have to say that this
is probably one of my favorite comic
book arcs of all time
so i thought i'd go into black noir so
we can really get a grip
on where this show could be going in the
future now in order to talk about him
properly
we have to talk about homelander himself
the comic culminates with him turning on
his masters at vaught
and the villain causes a superhero
uprising that ends with them surrounding
the white house
whilst he sits in the oval office
holding the president's head in his
hands
it's at this point that mother's milk
discovers the darkest secret about the
character
and what really led to this moment we
learned that homeland
was pretty much a science experiment
that was actually grown from
stonefront's dna stormfront was just a
kid that was injected with compound v
but homelander was supposed to be the
refined version of what a superhero
could be
and vo worked on the character before he
was even born
when homelander's mother was pregnant
she was injected with copious amounts of
compound v
and paid to carry the fetus to term
however
things went awry and homelander ripped
his way out of his mother's abdomen
and burned most of the scientists there
with laser beams
needless to say vort were completely
terrified by this
and thus they raised him underground
with a nuke beside him at all times
board had put a lot of money into
homelander and they didn't really want
to pull the plug on him just yet because
of one incident
so they simply kept him in their labs
watched over him
and tried to import on him social cues
and how to interact as a human
after a while they determined that they
couldn't really blame a newborn baby for
doing what it did and put it down as a
one-off mistake that wasn't really the
child's fault
however they also realized that they
needed a contingency plan in place to
kill homelanders should it ever come to
it
and as a bomb isn't that practical they
decided to do something else
with homelanders dna profile vort built
something new something better and that
was black noir
noir was the perfect clone of homelander
and he didn't dissipate the company
they trained him to be a master of
martial arts and imparted on him one job
in life
which was to kill homelander should it
ever come down to it
now homelander had no idea about noir
and he was happy as he got to be in
charge of the group
mirroring this black noir was happy as
well as
he was with his target at all times and
should he ever get the word
he could complete the mission with these
homelander actually started to like noir
throughout their time together
as he saw him as a loyal lap dog that
was willing to do whatever he said
no matter what black noir played things
perfectly too
and he even hid the majority of his
power set so that no one suspected a
thing
on 911 when the seven were called in to
help noir actually fell from one of the
planes
and didn't fly in order to keep up the
charade he was also given a jet by vault
which he attempted to use
in order to make it seem like he didn't
have the same power set as homeland
did however black noir became more and
more agitated
that he was unable to carry out his one
reason for being
slowly this itch scratched away at him
and the character retreated inside
himself
refusing to talk to psychiatrists or
anyone in general
thus he slowly went insane and decided
to enact a plan in order to frame
homelander
so that vaul could call on him in order
to kill the character
as he was the perfect clone of
homelander he one day dressed up as him
and carried out several atrocities that
included cannibalizing a baby
and killing several people noir took
photographs of the entire thing
and he sent them to both the boys as
well as vote
the cia didn't really know what to do
with them and thus they kept them back
as blackmail material
in case they ever needed to bring down
the seven as for vote
they almost issued the kill order but
because homelander made them so much
money
they decided to classify it as an
isolated incident
noir then went on to rape billy butch's
wife becky
who yeah look i know she's called becca
in the show but
it's becky in the in the comics yeah
just before you saw anyway
where was that all right he impregnated
her and then the fetus ripped its way
out of her womb
just like homelander did several years
before billy found becky's diary
and as she says that it was homelander
who did it the rivalry between the two
began
but still no kill order came black noir
was furious
and when you think about it the
character is pretty much like the
hardest hitter in baseball
that's been forced to sit on the bench
when he could be out there playing in
the field
doing what he was made for the character
was the most powerful person on earth
but because vogt wouldn't give the kill
order he had to hide this from everyone
and seem like second best whilst
homelander paraded around like he was
the king of the world
black noir was left with little options
so what he did next
is that he sent the photographs to
homeland of him carrying out the
atrocities
and this actually emboldened the villain
homelander even says in the end that he
would never have carried out any evil
acts
had he not believed that he'd already
done them and the villain is pretty much
manipulated into causing his uprising
at the white house noir revealed this
and he and homelander
went head to head noir actually punched
homelanders so hard that his jaw came
flying off
and he managed to kill him completing
his goal on the outside the marines
bombarded the white house with firepower
and noir came out smiling laughing over
finally getting what he wanted
the character could be seen holding half
of homelander in his hands
and he stood there with his intestines
spilling out all over the white house
lawn
billy went over and cracked open his
skull with a crowbar
and he pulled out a piece of his brain
saying that he hoped he was holding the
part in his hand
that contained the memories of his night
with becky butcher crushed it in his
hands
and thus the character was dead and so
ends black noir
i'm not crying no you're crying never
never forget
now if you still haven't subscribed to
the channel and now it's the perfect
time to do it as we make breakdowns like
this every day
and you definitely don't want to miss
them also giving away three copies of
the marvel phase two box set
and all you have to do to be with the
chance of winning is make sure you
subscribe to the channel
drop a like and also a comment below the
winner is going to be chosen at random
on the 30th of november and the set will
be shipped out from then
just in time for christmas best of luck
to everyone who takes part
and i hope that you enjoy the rest of
the video now
as for noir as a character himself as
you probably worked out
he's pretty much the boy's version of
batman not only is he a master in
hand-to-hand combat
he's also the strong silent type has a
jet
and yes it does come in black noir also
sticks
his thumb up huey's butt at one point
and says
good soldier good soldier which is a
reference to the dark knight returns now
homelander
noir and maeve pretty much make up the
trinity of the group
but he actually has other inspirations
that he pulls from
weaponry wise noir has a lot of
similarities with deadpool
and his skin tight attire has been
picked on purpose
so that the pair resemble each other
however whereas deadpool is known as the
merc with the mouth
noir is the complete opposite and
through the hundreds of pages that tell
the story of the boys
he barely even speaks his outfit too has
several similarities to snake eyes
and it's clear that he's riffing on a
number of characters
now in addition to this i've always seen
him as a sort of parody of bizarro
in dc law bizarro was pretty much a
clone of superman
that was his opposite in several ways
whereas homelander is bright and
bombastic
noir is low-key and chilled and they
very much are opposites to one another
even though they come from the exact
same genes either way
noir is an incredible villain and i
think everyone who read the reveal in
the comics can attest to it being a
mind-blowing moment
that came completely left field
mind-blowing because because of the the
brain bit hey haven't that any
anyway that that should be everything
you need to know about black noir in the
comics
and whether the show goes this route or
not is it is a different manner
but as it seems to be diverting from it
i thought i'd take some time to talk
about what the villain is really like
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on black noir and the comics in
general
if you enjoyed this video then please
drop a thumbs up and make sure you check
out our full breakdown of everything we
know so far about season 3 which is
going to be linked at the end
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat to us on the
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been paul and
i see you next time
take care peace
you